bonjour je me présente je suis à aida je
recherche un emploi d'assistant de
direction ou secrétaire de direction
j'ai le permis je suis j'ai un véhicule
également je suis je suis mobile
géographiquement
j'ai travaillé dans le secteur du
secrétariat je sais tenir les agenda je
sais recevoir le public j'ai réalisé la
gestion de des courriers je sais
utiliser les logiciels Microsoft Office
j'ai une formation de BTS action
commerciale j'ai également une licence
AES un dog d'économie d'administration
économique et sociale et une licence
l'administration économique et sociale
en plus j'ai récemment effectué un titre
à la parade Saint-André en CCP
comptabilité au niveau de la paye donc
j'ai réactualisé toutes mes formations
et mes connaissances j'espère que ma
candidature sera sélectionnée j'espère
attirer votre attention à travers cette
émission